let's talk about Sudan because the war
there has dipped out of the headlines
and the countries basically collapsing
fighting started in mid-april it's been
unrelenting and it's spreading there's
always the sound of bonfires anywhere
there's always a sound of artillery
waking you up the war literally has not
spared anyone the scale and speed of
Sudan's descent into death and
destruction is unprecedented so if
you've not been following what's going
on in Sudan here are five things you
need to know
let's start with who's fighting who
there are two main players you've got
General Abdel fatah al-braham he's the
head of the Sudanese armed forces and
then there's General Muhammad hamdan
dagalo also known as hemeti he leads the
rapid support forces the rsf there are
powerful paramilitary group the quick
backstory here is that General Abraham
and hemeti actually used to be on the
same side in 2019 there were big
pro-democracy protests against President
Omar al-Bashir who'd been in power for
three decades and the two generals kind
of hijacked those protests to overthrow
albashir but the protesters didn't want
the military in power either so they
kept up the pressure eventually a
caretaker government was set up with a
plan to transition sit down to a
democracy the two generals were part of
that but in 2021 they staged another
coup albraham took control of the
government and hamenty remained in a
powerful position over time though a
power struggle developed between them
especially over a plan to bring
hametti's forces the rsf under the
Army's command and in April that rivalry
turned into a full-on war they're trying
to not just win but trying to eradicate
the other in order to have complete
control over the country and its
resources okay so how are things looking
right now well a lot of the fighting is
concentrated in and around the capital
hartum is a war zone
but is not really clear which side has
got the upper hand the Army has managed
to hold on to its spaces and they've
also got planes
but the rsf controls more territory and
some key infrastructure they're in
facilities like oil refineries and water
plants and power plants some government
institutions they have more agile
vehicles that enable them to maneuver
cartoon streets they also have a lot
more troops deployed in cartoons about
1.4 million have fled the capital in
nearby cities according to the UN that's
around 15 percent of the population
there it means a lot of people are still
trapped civilians are getting killed in
the fighting whether it's from Street
battles artillery fire or air attacks
the rsf have also been accused of
terrorizing people homes have been
robbed and looted and destroyed occupied
vandalized and in this sexual violence
so it's just one big ball of uncertainty
for everyone what's going to happen to
me tomorrow is it going to be an
asteroid will the rsf come and try to
displace me from my home are they going
to try to Rob uh my house looking for
money and and gold and cars you just
never know and the city is barely
functioning Banks and most businesses
are shut hospitals have been attacked
and looted parts of Khartoum have had no
electricity for weeks
in one horrific incident at least 71
children and babies in an orphanage died
over several weeks because of hunger and
fever they were trapped because of the
fighting
that's the reality of the situation in
Khartoum right now and the fighting
between the rsf and the Army has spread
to other parts of the country too but
the next thing you need to know about is
what's happening in Darfur especially in
West Darfur one of its five states an
ethnic conflict has flared up again and
the UN says the violence could
constitute crimes against humanity
what's happening in Dark Forest is not
the same it's much worse it's an old
conflict being reignited again
in 2003 there was a rebellion in Darfur
it was mostly led by non-arab tribes who
felt discriminated against by the Arab
dominated government of President Omar
al-Bashir he responded by recruiting
fighters from Arab tribes to fight back
they became known as the janjaweed and
they were effective in stopping that
Insurgency but at an enormous human cost
they killed raped burned massively
displaced up to a third of the
population of Darfur as a whole keep in
mind that Omar al-Bashir was later
indicted by the international criminal
court because of what happened in Darfur
the janjaweed were led by hemeti in 2013
they were rebranded as the rsf a few
years later they were officially
recognized as a paramilitary force and
their links to Darfur have remained
strong they're aligned with local Arab
militias there and the rsf controlled
many gold mines a lucrative source of
revenue for them now while the rsf and
the Army are fighting against each other
in Khartoum and other parts of Sudan in
Darfur the Army seems to have retreated
and the rsf and Arab militias have been
able to pick up their old fights there
those militias continue to have the same
mindset the same mentality and based on
that they continue targeting the same
people they've been targeting since
2003. there are particularly harrowing
reports coming from elginina the capital
of westar4 including footage of bodies
lining the streets the Sudan doctors
union says more than a thousand people
have been killed there local tribe
leaders say it's more like 5 000. we
work with the community researchers
across Sudan and right at the beginning
of this conflict what has come across
from our colleagues and Janina was quite
Vivid the situation is catastrophic this
is
in essence nothing short of a really A
Renewed genocidal campaign they rob and
pillage and they kill especially those
who are unable to run the elderly
handicapped and the blind
the Arabs don't leave us alone when they
come they kill and rape and burn and
we're vulnerable if we let them they'll
burn our houses with the people inside
like Noor thousands of people have fled
from West R4 into Chad just across the
border 180 000 people from Sudan have
arrived in chat so since the conflict
started according to the U.N but it's
one of the poorest countries in the
world and doesn't have the
infrastructure to deal with a refugee
crisis on this scale there are no camps
people are trying to set up their own
camps using you know the clothes or the
Fabrics that they've brought with them
if they're able to they're looking for
shade everywhere water is an issue food
is an issue
unhcr is here they are doing assessments
and someone told us that they have never
seen it this bad that they are
incredibly underfunded they do not have
enough money to help people here with
anything
and this brings us to our next point the
war in Sudan has created an immense need
for humanitarian Aid and is not being
met about half the population of Sudan
25 million people now need some kind of
help aid groups working in the country
say they need three billion dollars this
year but have only received 446 million
donors recently promised another 1.5
billion still it's only half of what's
needed there hasn't been I think a
wake-up call across the world that this
is something that could destabilize an
entire region and we have seen this to
some degree in the ways in which you
know different countries have pledged
Aid if you compare that with other
conflicts particularly of course Ukraine
you'll see that the amounts pledged fall
far short of what's been committed there
there's another huge challenge with Aid
in sedan and that's how you actually get
it to the people who need it most it's
not just because there's fighting going
on both the Army and rsf have been
accused of restricting access to Aid and
stealing it dozens of offices and
warehouses belonging to Aid groups have
been looted and their vehicles have been
stolen
and what's happening especially in
Khartoum is that Sudanese people are
coming together to do whatever they can
groups of activists known as resistance
committees which were set up during the
pro-democracy protests are stepping in
they've been playing the role as you
know
the de facto government I would say
better than any other body on the ground
here they've been able to set up you
know clinics and and help run those
clinics those with medical experience
have been volunteering it's members of
the resistance committees that are
trying to connect power grids in parts
of the capital our final point is that
there really doesn't seem to be any
resolution to the war in sight there
have been some efforts to get the two
sides talking the African Union and an
East African Regional group known as
igad have been trying to mediate but the
main push so far has been from Saudi
Arabia and the U.S who've mediated a few
rounds of talks and Jetta the main
priorities have been to negotiate
ceasefires and humanitarian corridors so
that Aid can get in
but it's not worked we haven't seen
um the two sides even honor the
ceasefires and actually ceasefires have
been used by both sides
um as an opportunity to re-arm
um and to ensure that supply lines are
running both sides see this as an
existential struggle neither side is
ready to to to give tactical concessions
when they think that they might
um lose lose ground on the battlefield
or might forgo an opportunity for
winning as for the people of Sudan they
say this isn't their War what they're
focused on is surviving nobody knows
when it's going to end nobody knows how
it's going to end they don't know if
they're even going to survive tomorrow
so they're no longer even thinking about
the end of the conflict they're now
worried about their own tomorrow if
there's going to be a tomorrow
[Music]
if you want some more background on
politics in Sudan there's a good
explainer in our episode about the 2021
coup and make sure to subscribe to this
channel so you don't miss future
episodes of start here
[Music]